[Music]
guys I think all know me
hopefully online people know me too we
have one game for you as choice and then
and then nothing else so after this one
game I think what we're gonna do is play
online on me chess and then just do kind
of live play with commentary but let's
get to this game first it was from Tim
yes you can submit your game submit it
to this email address that Bensimon will
edit in and don't forget to send the new
games because I mean there is a game
shortage at the club right now and we do
need more games to to analyze ok we're
gonna get to the game this game is from
Tim from Alabama
it was a chest con game as far as I can
see it was a 10 minute game he wrote a
very long message with which I'm not
gonna read but if you want to like maybe
put it in the video the viewers can read
it themselves it was it was actually a
kind of an interesting game there were a
few interesting moments came from one my
favorite openings from the white side
but Tim was black and Tim pretty much
completely outplayed his opponent until
the very end he played a losing move but
then his opponent played an even worse
move and then Tim won the game so we'll
see what happens
it was King's pawn opening night of 3
and I see six and then one of my
favorite pet vines see 3 anyone know the
name of this anyone kanjyani yeah and I
really enjoy teaching this opening to
kids because it's a very easy opening to
understand from White's perspective is
if you think about it white is just
simply preparing pongy for just to take
over the center and that's usually one
of the goals in the opening just got to
center pawns one on d4 one on e4 and if
we look at this position from left side
there's not too many moves to prevent
pawn d4 I've seen a lot of people make
the mistake of playing Bishop c5
trying to control the d4 square another
time it's funny but Bishop c5 actually
makes d4 stronger like can still play it
because White has three defenders and
I've had this position a lot from whites
per sec perspective where after take
take like just takes over the center
gains time this Bishop has to move again
very pleasant from early on so if we go
back there's a few other better moves
for black one of them was played in the
game Knight f6 which we'll get to I
think probably my recommendation here is
to play d5 for black I don't know if you
guys have seen this before but it takes
advantage of the fact that if white
takes and black takes then why can't
play Knight c3 and this is one of the
major drawbacks of the kanjyani
if the pawn is left on c3 then like
can't develop and meanwhile the Queen
even though it's developed early it
can't easily be attacked and black would
have a good Center from this position so
I could spend like a whole other lecture
just delving into the lines after d5 I
will note the the best move for white is
Queen a4 and it gets into some
interesting and sharper territory but
let's stick with what happened in the
game black played Knight f6 white went
ahead play d4 and in this position black
has two main moves and usually when I
teach this to students I say that black
can either capture the e4 pawn or the d4
pawn and regardless of what move black
plays the best response for white is to
push the center pawn to attack a knight
so if we look at this in in real life if
I take the best move for a white is to
do what any one d5 yes and if we look at
this move pawn take T for best move for
white is again push the center pawn in
this case e pawn to attack that six
nights and the idea for white is he
wants to gain space as early as possible
and both of these moves are playable
black what happened in this game is you
take t4 was played and white failed to
play the best move white did not play e5
but rather took on d4 which is the first
kind of serious mistake of the game
because he's he's leaving his epon
undefended on e4 so real quick if we
look at the main line if we look at what
happens after e5 white actually gains
time attacking the knight in space black
would have to play Knight d5 and in this
position usually when I'm teaching this
to students I tell them don't take on d4
but just continue the initiative and
white has a crafty little move here in
Queen b3 again kicking the knight and
actually driving the knight out of the
center the night has not too many
options
the best option is Knight b6 and then
finally light can take back and I think
this is a very pleasant position to play
from the white side it's more space with
the pawns if we notice a knight can
develop freely to c3 the bishops usually
come in pretty naturally this is a
position I've had many times as white
and I usually enjoy playing but let's go
back see what happen the game after
white made the first mistake
black or Tim in this case gladly
accepted the gift on e4 and for the rest
of the game black was just up a pawn but
it was a matter of converting knack for
advantage so for a good portion of these
moves will go a bit quicker Knight c3
was played I like the move to Tim played
here
Bishop to b4 just pinning the the knight
to the King and getting ready to Castle
black or white replied bishop t2 and
then black played a move here which
maybe isn't the best move but still very
fine he went ahead he took on c3 and
then after take take take it was just a
trade a lot of simplifications if we go
back I think it would have been better
to leave the bishop on before because
it's a nice piece it's exerting pressure
and rather rather than take on c3 black
should take on d2
and what you're doing is you are
creating some opportunity for pain light
would probably take back with the Queen
and you leave your bishop here just
exerting pressure and then black is
ready to castle maybe get the rook to e8
and I think it's more pleasant for black
still up upon but in this case having
two bishops and just more pressure on
white let's go back
so black black kept things simple just
take take take take and next several
moves I'm not gonna have too much
commentary Queenie seven Bishop e2
Castle castle a very natural move d5
let's keep going until things get
interesting
rook e1 Queen goes off the e-file a lot
of natural moves okay Knight g5 first
kind of very aggressive move
White's threatening both this Bishop and
more importantly Queen take h7 so I'm
gonna leave it up to you guys flack to
move here and don't and don't blunder
what would you play
I think bishop at five is extremely
reasonable yeah
just get the bishop out of danger get
temple on the Queen defend h7
I will admit I forget what Tim played
but Bishop f5 is probably my choice I'll
see what he played you played g6 which
maybe it looks a bit stranger I think
it's still fine though this a bishop is
defended by the Queen on g4 g6 in some
cases are weakening but in this case mmm
it does its job defends it defends age
of 7 and it's hard to relate to exploit
the weak dark squares anyway let's keep
going take take take take
so more simplifications the knight is
currently hanging on g5 white retreats
and now 97 just kind of a weird move but
I think the point is black wants to
perhaps maneuver the Knights a the Kings
side and also solidify the Queen side
with him move like c6
if we notice in the previous position
this night isn't really doing too much
on c6 kind of like a nothing piece and
this is very common especially in more
common than Queens pawn openings when
the Knights on c6 and White has a
structure apology for apply on c3
the knight is just like dominated so I
think 97 is a reasonable move
maybe another option I don't know how
good this would be actually it would
probably be a very bad option but I'll
show it anyway isn't it a 5 sometimes
this is possible to try and get the
Knight to c4 where it would be a nice
outpost but the problem here is Queen B
5 and this is is this lit this is a
quadruple fork the pawn other Khan the
knight the rook and black would be
forced to lose at least upon here knight
c6 would be best and then take okay so 9
a5 not a great move a decent positional
idea but tactics are are clearly very
important ok 97 was played white played
c4 and we're going to keep going until
the tackle moment any question out here
something
no okay tick here Queen take c7 take t4
and coming up I think this is a moment a
white just plays 95 very aggressive move
attacking both the Queen and the f7 pawn
twice so black is under pressure here
and this is a really critical moment
because things are getting tactical and
it's very important for black to be
precise here so I'm gonna leave it up to
you guys black to move what would you
play in the position rook take E five
anyone agree so two votes worth taking
five any other moves you know their
suggestions any anyone against rook
taking five sure Queen off for a very
playable but maybe general consensus
still rookie five
okay so Marlar know this something rook
take you five is actually a losing move
or it's very bad move
you're not not quite losing but very bad
now what you're probably well you
probably know this first with rook
taking five is a fact that rook taking
five Queens egg e5 neither three check
this is winning for black and that's
what Tim probably calculated and that's
what he played he played rook taking
five
unfortunately for black after a rook
tikki five white to move and find the
winning move do you see it Alex
you want to say it yeah yeah queen bee a
very instructive moment not immediately
recapturing the rook but first checking
the King provoking the King to move to
g7 is basically the only move and then
you take the rook and then you check so
there's no time for Knight f3 I think
this was really instructive because it
demonstrates the whole concept of
Intermezzo or in-between move or instead
of doing like an obvious recapture you
play some may be more subtle move first
in this case Queen be a check and it
would lead to a black just being out
material after King g7 take black is our
sorry leading to white being out
material white has exchanged for a pawn
so should be great winning chances for
whites so unfortunately for for Tim's
opponents he took on e5 with the Queen
and then he just went on to lose really
unfortunate it's the type of thing like
sometimes you'll play a game like this
and you'll go without realizing there is
a tactical opportunity and that's why
it's really important to kind of go back
analyze your games and try and figure
out where the improvements were where
the missed tactics were because that's
how you're going to learn and I think
Tim gave some very like long comments I
don't know where it was exactly
maybe after Queen f5 yeah so if we go
back to this position Queen f5 is a
stockfish choice just defend the Queen
defend the f7 point I think Queen f4 is
probably very similar and black would be
in very good shape here still up upon
having the initiative Queen safe pawn on
f7 safe and great winning chances for
luck so that was a game after rook take
e5 Queen take e5 Knight f3 not really
much more to look at
I think oh the game was abandoned that's
the worst when you're winning a game and
your opponent just like disconnects and
then you have to
for them to fact I guess it happens on
online sometimes well thank you Tim for
sending in your game only only viewers
choice game for today if you want to
send in your games this is a reminder
send it to this email address it will be
in the description in the video and
players like me when we're teaching
we're very grateful to have games to go
over makes things interesting so I think
what we're gonna do now is move on to
some other type of lecture which should
still be interesting for the viewers and
this is something I do actually kind of
on my own I do kind of a live stream
version of it we're all kind of play
games online with commentary and we'll
kind of talk through the plans in the
position hopefully we'll get to play
some good players we're gonna go on to
Lee chess does anyone play on me chess
one too few people okay a great site
completely free very easy to get games
yes okay let's do blitz then wait is
there a blitz arena to join let's try
this this is the hourly puts arena okay
this is five-minute chess and we can
just join this and it should just start
a game within a few seconds and
sometimes this is how I train like I'll
just play blitz online maybe try out
some new openings that's a good way to
teach to hopefully hopefully you'll get
to have some insight into my thought
process while I while I play a game okay
so we're playing a 1421 any opening
suggestions these six we have e six
French okay and I will take opening
suggestions from people so if you you
have a favorite opening let me know you
know to do I can c4 c4 is rare but it's
playable the best move here is d5 and
the idea is we want to create some
exchanges and if white takes then
there's going to be a weak pawn
structure for whites
now the obvious move is Queen take t5
the best move is minus six we want the
night to come to to d5 this is one of
the reasons why the c4 line isn't that
popular so we'll take the pawn and while
I'm playing this if anyone wants to like
shout out a mover you have questions
about something just let me know Paul
just continue my my play he's attacking
our knight twice so we can move we could
capture we could try and defend we
capture we kind of fix his I said Queens
pawn well he could with he would take
towards the center so like take the cake
I'm gonna play my first choice might be
six we moved the night but we attack the
bishop so we're not really losing too
much time and I think what's really
important in a position like this we
want to develop as quickly as possible
and try and castle before he castles and
if we can do that and ideally if we can
get a rook on ei before he castles then
it would be golden
so Queenie to actually helps us do this
because we're gonna play Bishop e7 and
if we can castle play rook e8 his king
and queen are aligned on efile
and that's some potential problems for
him he's probably gonna cast the next
move we can't stop them so let's just
Castle ourselves so now rook e8 maybe
not a huge threat rook e8 might actually
lead to some problems there's some
potential tactical problems on f7 so I
think we should leave the rook here for
now
and probably just continue developing
let's go for Bishop g4 we're still in
that phase of the game we want to get
our pieces to good squares before we do
anything crazy and actually with this
move we have some idea of taking because
this Queen was was defending the knight
and the bishop so he plays a logical
move let's continue developing
I'm trying to play quickly on moments
which don't need too much thinking this
moment is interesting there's a couple
of options we could retreat or we can
play the counter-attacking move 94 I
think both moves perfectly perfectly
playable does anyone have any preference
94 yeah why not sometimes the best
defense is offense I like 94 because
we're threatening to if he moves his
Queen we want to take take and win the
pawn ooh this case we're just winning
the Queen Queen's undefended that's
that's very pleasant let's take the
Queen
maybe he'll resign maybe he won't
it's probably just crying right now okay
that's nice okay I think that was a that
was a pretty smooth game and sometimes
that's how you uh you beat weaker
players you just wait for them to hang
their queen no offense to the weaker
players out there but yeah there was
some early initiative like we actually
developed quicker than them if we go
back to this position it seemed like he
was developing quicker than us however I
think Knight b6 was important move
kicking the bishop or at least
pressuring the bishop and then Bishop g4
another important move there's already
like issues for him because if we wanted
to take he couldn't take back with Queen
because the bishop paintings that he
took back with Paul and his King side
would be opening and then all of a
sudden like we had we were developing
but we also had threats and that's the
best way to develop develop make threats
win the Queen okay let's go back
hopefully we get one more game before
this tournament ends these tournaments
are cool because they don't wait for
anyone to finish they they automatically
pair you with someone else who just
finished their game but there will be
some waiting here
94 players playing in this tournament
we're already in 61st place it basically
free-for-all yeah they have some
algorithm sorry
I'm not gonna win because I joined like
way too late
oh no the pairings are closed that
that's the problem with with timing so
you get you get virtual trophies so if
you take like top three you get like a
virtual trophy so it's some incentive
unfortunately okay there's a lot of like
all these tournaments are ending and so
I can't join them there is a classical
arena which is ten minute chess which
maybe I'll play one classical game and
then come back to blitz just want to try
and play as many games as possible so
we'll join this some tournaments that
they run are for money actually they're
very rare but they do happen and they'd
like pay you in Bitcoin it's it's weird
but I don't think you can become rich
off of that
okay I need suggestions other than the
French I play c5 we just stick with that
okay I'm a huge fan of time on O
Sicilian
unfortunately we can't play time on of
against this this is a Smith Morra
anyone play Sicilian is whack few people
okay this is not a Smith more this is
just a dubious opening because the Queen
is developed too early we're gonna try
and use the same strategy as asking just
develop and make threats and try and
develop quicker than whites
let's play Knight of 6
I do that I don't think I've ever seen
Queen take T 4 followed by Queen D 1 I
guess it's playable for wait any
suggestions here like how to develop a
few different moves for black yeah I
like g6 yeah being kind of the bishop
resembling some sort of like Sicilian
dragon
we can play Bishop g7 usually I say that
like you should develop your Kings side
and castle before you develop your Queen
sides in most cases lets castle I should
note we're not afraid of a 5 because we
had a Knight G for this position we
definitely want to take with Bishop well
he's being very aggressive h4 he wants
to kill us
like h5 if he gets maybe 5 moves in a
row he can check me this but h4 probably
a bit dubious any suggestions here for
black like how send me h4 so we play h5
should we do something else I really
like Queen a5 I'm gonna play that's a
slow type of move I think we can play
without doing too much calculation
because we're automatically at
pressuring the Knights we're also kind
of controlling the 5th rank so maybe
discouraging h5 in some cases and we're
kind of targeting his king - Queen d3
logical
this position there's a few moves that
stick out like right away
the first movie I would consider is
night to be four I don't know if it's
the best move when you play it move like
night before you want to have like some
some calculation in mind if we play
night before he would have to move his
queen and you have to move his Queen to
a square which defends he too so he
would probably play Queen d2 and I'm not
entirely sure if there's a follow up and
I might might just be misplaced on on
before there's another move I'm looking
at which is very thematic for this
position it might be a sacrifice someone
said that I think d5 yeah and I think d5
is probably the principle move here one
night before and then d5 that's also
possible when we play d5 we have the
threat of d4 so it's probably going to
transpose like he'll probably take him
then we play night before the line I'm
looking at is d5 safety 594 Queen d2 and
then we just continue building up
pressure like Bishop a5 attacking c2 I
would think at some point we would win
the pawn back on d5 yeah but probably
not before first it should make a
difference
and this is one of the one of the ways I
see a lot of like amateur players go
down quickly as they'll they won't
Castle quickly enough and then their
King gets exposed in the center 'if I've
not expected it looks like we can take
on e5 we also have Bishop f5 we also
have night before so many
delicious-looking moves I mean why not
just grab a free pawn take on e5
sometimes this is where I'm weakest like
I'll spend too long
debating between all these good moves
and I should really just play one of
them and not take too much time let's
just take the free pawn I guess maybe he
wanted the D file to stay close but we
still have a lot of pressure in the
position I should note if he plays Queen
take d5 we played Bishop takes c3 and we
win his queen so some tactical
possibilities we're still threatening
pawn D fork to still ideas a bit about
five a three
so random
okay let's take a vote Bishop f5 or D
for who votes for Bishop f5 okay let's
do it expecting Queen d2 maybe we just
play both Bishop f5 and then d4 is my
it's going to be awkward
I'm just trying to calculate here defy
or D for the night's gonna go maybe to
eat - and maybe we avoid the Queen trade
somehow I mean that looks very uh very
pleasant for black and whites just
completely passive whoa b4 okay black to
move when a piece take the Knights yeah
I think we just want to make sure he has
no sneaky move with his Queen but this
looks like it wins a knight another one
of these in turn esos he was expecting
us to move his queen but we just take
his Knight yeah that was brutal he was
probably much worse in this position
already like 90 to 92 we would probably
we would want to avoid the Queen trade
because his King stole in the center so
usually if your pawns King was less safe
you want keep Queens on the board
probably Queen d5 it's so pleasant for
that Oh Queen b6 - yeah Queen b6 is very
illogical attack me - okay that was
another feel-good game and kind of
similar nature of the previous game
where like he didn't develop quickly
enough and then just got into trouble
like very early I didn't do it do
anything too special in that game okay
let's go back to the tournament page oh
there's no five-minute chess but we
could play we could play three two which
is similar I've been playing the London
myself it's one of these openings like
it's it's easy it like low levels to
understand oh I'm so sorry I don't know
if we can play London against e6 this
Bishop f4 is just it's not a good move
against e6 we're gonna play Kirk we're
gonna play d4 so one one situation where
we don't play London
okay he's playing like a perk modern
type thing I'm gonna play my my secret
preparation let's start with Bishop e2
and he was something sir
oh you can't be watching this is I don't
know what's going on I was so excited to
use my secret preparation this is just a
secret okay I might as well explain like
the idea of efficient you two like why
do resigned to rating points at leas so
neither three is most common but Bishop
e2 the idea is after Knight f6 to play
h4 with idea quick h5 makes things more
sharp more interesting okay let's go
back third place
oh this is 57 minutes so we won't play
the whole thing
we'll play until the next luxury starts
twitch yeah I only started like a month
ago but me chest features my stream on
their front page so it's cool get good
amount of viewers and this is usually
what I do on the live streams I just
play games I like talked through with
commentary and then I'll interact with
people in the chat too okay another
black game and you need suggestions we
played east six we played c5 okay yeah
yeah that other game wasn't really a
truce to ceiling play you six I've
noticed a lot of people are playing like
anti Sicilians these days it's hard to
get an open ceiling in c3 that's
probably expected let's play d5 d3 ok
another kind of bizarro opening
sometimes white plays e5 tries to
transpose to a French this position I
think we should just play the I mean we
could trade Queens immediately or we
could play a bit more I don't quite a
bit more close position
let's keep Queens on the board I think
it will lead to more interesting middle
game
yeah the issue is like he already played
c3 which gives the king and I square on
c2
he had there should be five with tempo
but this is looking like a very good
French because if he wants to play d4 he
loses time and if he plays that let's
continue attacking the pawn like three
attackers yes to play Bishop for this
position there's some options I'm gonna
start with h6 idea of t5 so h4 is very
natural and then we're gonna play g6 and
we just want one more attacker actually
realizing maybe this wasn't the best
option because he can play d4 at some
point but we'll go for it it's still
solid for black if he does play d4 well
in this case he okay question can we
take the pawn and not lose anything this
is interesting if we take the pawn he
takes well then we take with bishop this
might be okay take t4 if he plays d4 we
take with check on f3 I think it's okay
it looks risky because there's this very
annoying looking pin but it should be I
mean if we went up on me when Apollo
that's that's nice and at least I'll
think here
whoa kimchi - kimchi - as a move I don't
know what we do after that I think we
just take the bishop now well he can
still play King G - these without the
Bishop Bishop taking six is so weird
now we take with Bishop now there's no
real pain anymore and we're just up a
piece Oh Queen take you six
I completely miss that someone should
have stopped me
but we're still okay right King f8 King
that fate
got a little too comfortable there but
we're still off a piece and he shouldn't
have too much too much play here he had
rookie one maybe okay so how do we
neutralize here maybe Queen c6 and just
get the Queen out of there we defend g6
if he wants to keep things on the board
he has to retreat a pretty far distance
if we trade Queens were happy if he
retreats to me we build up some maybe
some sort of attack on the Kings side
yeah let's play this
he still has rookie one but at least
Yates hovered maybe he's Savin we would
have to defend sorry Queen d6 he takes
here keeps attacking the Queen
I was thinking rook h7 just making sure
that there's no entry points I mean he
could take this pawn but we would just
want to develop and now he's thinking
about Knight f3 and 95
let's stop and let's play Bishop g4 also
may be planning rookie rookie AIDS and
we're up at peace and in a blitz
situation like this we just want to not
allow any sort of like unnecessary
initiative from the opponent not do
anything too crazy either let's play
rook e8 Queen d4 decent move can play
rook e7
and the e-file is actually the only
opening file so by doubling up we
actually take over the file and this is
looking a lot more comfortable I think
we should go for some some kill that
Queenie six and then maybe like Bishop
h3 queen g4 ideas as king is uh it's
pretty naked on g1 just a matter of
improving the pieces
and he's so restricted like his Knight
wants to come to e5 but can't his rook
wants to come to you one but can't
so these positions are really tough to
play from the white side I'm just worse
thinking here if we play Bishop h3 he
plays King here 99 lakhs ok well let's
play Bishop h3 King eh - can we play
Queenie - check probably not
ok let's move quickly
since play goes about 5 now we want to
play Queen e2 somehow infiltrates
we also might want to flag him might be
the most direct way of winning let's
play king f7 how reinforcing the g6 and
ff6 targets if we play Queen e2 there he
has rookie to had rookie - that's a
decent move shift the rook over if the D
file opens we want to work on the D file
okay let's take the pawn
threatening the Knights if he takes our
queen we take with Bishop defending this
pawn
still of a piece oh he dropped tonight
that's nice
please play kingi 3 9 H 5 would be mates
yes
ok that was maybe more interesting game
still got an advantage from pretty early
on there were some interesting points
around here maybe this whole like h6 g6
idea wasn't the best I was actually
thinking like he should probably just
play d4 here because then our bishop is
just kind of dead on g7 staring at the
pawn chain but he he went into this line
and then someone suggested like a really
interesting move King g2 let's just open
this in analysis so King g2 here which
is very very crafty like King g2 is a
quiet mood but the whole purpose is we
now can't take on f3 with Czech so we
can't easily resolve the pin and white
is now threatening d4 rook e1 so
anything to do here for a black or are
we just losing a piece
before you said d4 OD for to prevent d4
is interesting d4 and then let's say
rook e1 Oh black to move here there's a
nice move
yes giving away a taste of his own
medicine so getting out of the pin and
then pinning white and therefore
defending e5 even though white has it
looks like white house with four
attackers but the knight spins and the
Queen needs the battery so white can't
win anything on e5 and black just
neutralizes everything in black someone
having initiative here very nice V for
Queen c6 I like it I wonder if we would
have found that yeah so probably pawn
takes pawn best and then take oh I could
win this so that was just a trailer
fauns and then probably lacking doubt of
the pin I clean b6 year
I think I would prefer black it's still
equal material but like there's targets
in whites position like t3 is isolated
and kind of weak you choose a target I
like this Bishop box ready to Castle
White's setup looks just weird like
Bishop on that for Bishop on h3 King on
g2 okay that was uh other cool game or
cool moment the rest of the game was
just converting up a piece took some
work but sometimes that's what you have
to do is you have to China just kind of
the push the just the safety button play
a bunch of safe moves defend against all
threats restrict your opponent and then
when when later in that game okay let's
go back try again get in a couple more
games in seventh place there are like
some like occasionally some strong play
reason to play on the side though
Yaser Sarah one was talking to me
yesterday like he's a big fan of the
site but he plays crazy house a huge fan
of crazy house okay new game we're
playing white any suggestions we'll play
d4 we only had one white game it was
like four moves
well played London you start with Bishop
f4 okay knight c6 this is what amateur
players do against the London it's not a
great move kind of what I referred to
earlier we're gonna play III here
nice e6 is usually not good in Queens
pawn opens because it just blocks the C
pawn which usually likes to move let's
just continue development
I should note there's one idea with
knight c6 which is might be for but then
we play Knight a3 and black has no
attack any ideas what to do here how to
develop
I'd like c4 personally because that way
they play
he takes e5 they take say for you
quickly should take see for yourself
yeah I think that's very playable
sometimes c4 might invite Bishop before
check but then we have Knight c3
I think c4 is very reasonable I like it
and yet our development is nice c3 so
then we get our pawn in front of the
night so the pawn and Knight work
together to pressure d5 sometimes we
even have Queen b3 and we also have
ideas of rook c1 oh he said exactly what
you said exactly what's gonna happen
there should take c4 let's play Knight
c3 and someday probably later in the
middle game we'll get the rook to c1 and
there might be some pressure on the C
file in the meantime you should complete
opening principles just castle Queen
okay he just give up or gave up the
bishop hair and a pretty open position
and we're very happy with two bishops
and we're actually threatening a fork in
this position which we can't do right
away but we're still threatening it
anyone see a fork between g3 yeah very
sneaky I think that allows it wait a
minute Queens you 39.5 mmm and he'll
probably find that at five let's play d4
I like it still threatening the fork
Queen g3 he would play probably rook c8
when Bishop h6 is enough with my g6
okay let's start with growing g3 just
tickle him a little bit
Brookes case will only move IC to defend
the pond and we're gonna start with roof
p1 this is very easy quick let's move
attack another target and one of the
points is if he plays b6 we played
Bishop Asics and we're winning I think
we're winning a pawn and maybe even the
exchange because his rook gets awkward
maybe trapped I think he has to play
Knight a5 which he did let's play Bishop
d3 and his Knights a bit misplaced ok
he's attacking our Bishop we don't want
to allow the trade night for Bishop so
we should retreat somewhere let's start
with Bishop any suggestions yeah okay
Bishop g5 I think that's that's
reasonable yeah if you place f6 that's
very weakening that's true
oh he played r6 so now we retreat
probably to e3
usually f6 that weakens u6 and might
weaken this and draw arrows weekend
diagonal it's nice still very in this
place but there's still work to do
c5 trying to exert some pressure but I
don't think it does too much let's play
h4 idea of h5
and there's a few different like areas
of the board where we can try and apply
pressure f5 I was not expected might be
a logical move though he wants to play
f4 we should probably take maybe take
and have the bishop return to g5 oh he's
debating whether to take on h4 but then
we take on e6 oh he takes on these four
I don't think this is very good for him
very dangerous pawn to bishops even more
open position his nights are very
awkward 9f5
it's a decent move
Queen h3 I like it targeting niya
targeting upon maybe supporting an e6
pawn it's a nice geometrical move and
the next pin to h7 we're maybe even
threatening g4 here
it's a crazy move but I mean why not
attack it in peace
we're also up upon lots of things going
right for the whites
g6 very logical hmm still work to do and
not too much time
okay let's just play I don't want to
think too long here just play a quick
move like rook t1
it's a D file might open at some points
and this is a point like we're below a
minute or just have to play quick not
blunder maybe even try and flag him and
also maybe most importantly keep the
initiative so you want to continue
trying to make threats
let's take here now we're opening the D
file or threatening Bishop take out five
attacking the Queen oh he takes there
okay let's take here
now we're threatening Bishop take g6
also threatening e7 you saw it it's like
on b6 and then we'll take
okay we're up a lot of ponds but it's
gonna come down to time or it's gonna
come down to rooks on the seventh
delivering checkmate
rook bb7 coming next let's do it if he
takes on c3 we play rope g7 this is
usually what you want in an endgame like
if you can get both rooks on the seventh
ranked is deadly I think I gave a whole
lecture on that like pigs on the seventh
the point here is after Queen take take
take we have the final capture on c3 and
it's pretty much forced
so flagging is one way to lose oh
there's increments I forgot there's
increments that's good to know
so we take on h7 and he's gonna be
forced to play Queen take g7 very bold
not resigning let's have some fun okay
okay that was a interesting game maybe
the highest quality game so far we
weren't winning right from the opening
it was one of these like common sort of
amateur lines with knight c6 it's kind
of a hard thing to punish but what we do
we just kind of developed normally put
the pieces on good squares Knight f3 c4
I think we got a very harmonious
development our pieces develop very
quickly and again I think every single
opponent that we played made the same
mistake like they didn't develop too
quickly like this Bishop II form of a
classic example like actually just
played Knight f6 here I'm in castle
beating two slightly better chances
Bishop before we got some very quick
initiative but still had to work for it
having the center having two bishops
it's nice but it still takes work to
convert the damage if we go forward I
like this [ __ ] g5 those in my suggestion
and then moving back and then c5
yeah and at some point black just had a
lot of weaknesses go forward but he
played well like he came up with some
nice defensive moves g6 being one of
them I think this is a moment where I
kind of froze up wasn't sure quite what
to do
I think rook d1 turned out to be a good
move if we notice in this position
likewise pieces are pretty well placed
work on b1 to bishops Queen they're all
doing something this what rook was only
rook that wasn't doing anything and
sometimes this is what stronger players
look for especial it's just identifying
a worse place piece and then just
finding the fighters Square for it I
move like rook d1 doesn't require too
much calculation it just requires kind
of the right thought process and
identifying the piece you want to
improve so Brooke team 1 and then that
opening up tactics or he had no time to
take back on c5
and then the final the finale of the
game yeah rooks on the sudden very
deadly okay it is almost time to finish
does anyone have any questions about
games we played or any quick questions
you want to ask me anyone I think we're
gonna end it there almost 7:30 thanks
for watching
reminder again send in your games to to
this email address and we will hopefully
be back with viewers games to analyze
and I'll have to play people online
[Music]